welcome back well after the local
election results it's not the easiest
week for cabinet ministers to come on
shows like this and defend the
government but fortunately the cabinet's
newest member
Rory Stewart it's used to all that after
months of defending the Prime Minister's
brexit deal on the airwaves his reward
was being made the new International
Development Secretary and he's here in
the studio now thank you very much for
being on the program and it feels like
we should start with the local election
results which were really a bit of a
bloodbath for the Conservative Party I
mean down more than 1300 councillors I'm
sure that you followed the results very
closely as they came in and what point
did you realize just how bad things well
I think it became clear quite early and
I think one of the very interesting
things about this is how much this is
about bricks that it's not really about
the local councillors who many of them
have done an incredible job and I think
it's hugely frustrating for them because
they're trying to focus on issues that
really matter to people locally and I
think it's important for a local
democracy that people vote for people
for what they're responsible for so
they're paying the price for the
government's failure to take the UK out
of the EU
labour and conservatives at the moment
are suffering from this whole brexit
thing tortuous some endless brexit thing
and we've got to get beyond it the
message of this we got to get beyond it
but there's another message if you look
at the detail of those results look at
places like sand or ones look at the
fact that really where the Conservatives
were losing their votes most are in the
moderate center ground seats and that
shows we need a bricks that deal that we
shouldn't follow this idea that somehow
the future of the Conservative Party is
trying to outdo Nigel Faraj the future
of a party like the Conservatives and
indeed should be true for labour to is
in the centre ground the British
politics when are you worried that the
remain voting conservatives will never
come back to the party I believe they
will come back but I believe we've got
to work very very hard to get them back
and we've got to reassure them above all
that we're not going to go for an
unnecessary damaging no do Bret said but
that we can get a brexit that is
pragmatic works well and keeps us close
to Europe economically I just want to
have a look at something just to
illustrate just how bad the night was
for the
I mean these show your local election
results from 1995 to 2019 and you can
see that really the only comparable
result is back in 1995 it's going to
take you a long time to recover from
this isn't it so it's been a big impacts
if you look at those results what you'll
see is that labor actually lost a lot of
seats during the Blair government but
they tended to lose them more steadily
in our case this is we did recently well
in 2015 as the governing party and as
you see there we we suffered badly in
2019 but this is a brexit effect this is
people's frustration the fact that
Parliament is not delivering they want
it done they want to move on there are
so many things that all of us can talk
about as matter whether you're a Lib Dem
or labral conservative about this
country about housing a climate
particular at the moment and we've got
to get back to that Center ground and
that's the way that we'll take these
seats back that's the way that we'll win
an election but above all that's where
we'll restore people's faith in
government I just wonder if your
analysis is right to focus on those
remain voting seats in the local
elections we're clearly to very badly
the brexit Party weren't standing were
they so in the European elections we
could see a completely different picture
can we yes much worse it's true they
weren't standing but it's also very
important to understand in 2017 I mean
if we get onto the electoral math of
this most brexit voters voted for the
Conservative Party but four million
remain voters voted for the conservative
party if the conservative party were to
make the mistake of trying to outdo
Nigel Faraj which I'm sure we won't but
it is something that a few of my
colleagues are talking about then we
would lose those 4 million remained
voters we lose young people we'd lose
Scotland we've lose London and we'd lose
a lot of the most energetic parts of
this country we've got to be a board
party we've got to be able to stretch
all the way from Ken Clark right the way
through to Jacob Riis mark is the
problem partly your leader in Duncan
Smith is called on Theresa May to
announce her resignation
I'm really strongly disagree with us I
think this idea that somehow it's all to
do with an individual is naive the this
is about brexit this is about the fact
we have a country
which is divided right down the middle
or the Prime Minister must be
responsible for the brexit policy well
the premise is responsible break spots
and she's done it hasn't been able to
get through yes and like several
attempts all that is true so she's put a
very courageous effort in trying to get
something through a divided Parliament
without a majority and with a very split
country but honestly I didn't think
anybody doing that role I didn't think
if some sort of superhero turned up
George Clooney suddenly became Primus oh
I don't think he'd be able to charm his
way through this problem the problem
it's not the individual race to resume
it has written a piece in the mail on
sunday today effectively laying down the
gauntlet for jeremy corbyn back a deal
together let's put up let's listen to
what the voters said in a local election
she says let's do a deal I mean do you
think that that is now the way forward
it's not my preference not the Prime
Minister's preference we would have much
preferred the Prime Minister's deal but
yes there's now that has to be the right
option even if it's a customs union a
permanent customs but the details this
have to be worked out right but I don't
think labour wants to restrict our
future trade policy I don't think they
want to allow unrestricted immigration
they might have control over English and
so we agree on so many things
what neighbor one is a permanent customs
union when we heard it from John
Ashworth and in the program we've had it
consistently on what they've been
talking about is they keep saying they
want a permanent customs union where the
UK has control over trade negotiations
with other countries so they're talking
about something it doesn't really exist
out there while they're talking about
sort of Turkey triple plus we need to
see the details this but really our
positions are about a quarter of an inch
apart we agree on 99% of this stuff and
there is an advantage to switch people
are not talking about which is if we can
get a cross-party deal then there's a
possibility that it will remain it'll be
more sustainable and be more stable in
other words when a government changes of
party changes we're not gonna have
bricks that suddenly turned on its head
we need investors to feel this will be
there for 30 years not just for four
years and a cross-party deal is a way to
do that but that's exactly what some
people in your party are so scared about
isn't it that a customs union will be
agreed with labour that in their minds
takes away
all of the benefits of leaving the
European Union and the neg is nowhere
Tom Poquette well sort of to to set
prices first see it's not true that this
would take away all the benefits from
leaving the European Union I mean even
in the very worst case scenario Turkey
is obviously not in the European Union
if you were to go down that option you'd
have full control of freedom of movement
the City of London wouldn't be regulated
you'd be free on services you wouldn't
be paying tens of billions of pounds a
year to the or immediately got on the
bus I would you vote to leave and be
like tacking no we're a much bigger
economy now we're an amazing country and
we're much larger economy and we have
far more potential net but the point
that I'm trying to make is that when
some of my colleagues say Britain would
be a vassal state their extraordinary
exaggerations this would be a real
brexit we'd leave the European
Commission we leave the Parliament but
more important that I just sort of keep
coming back to that is that what we
really need for the country is a deals
that lasts and pushing for an extreme
fairest I'll deal which has no real
majority support in the country and no
majority support in Parliament is
firstly impossible but secondly wouldn't
last through changes in Parliament so it
wouldn't be any good for investors okay
do you think the deals going to be done
I think a deal can be done if you mean a
lot it'll be done a lot of this a lot of
this rests on on to be honest one man on
whether Jeremy Corbyn really wants to
deliver a brexit deal but I think if he
wants to do it it'll be actually
surprisingly easy to do because our
positions are very very close to do the
deal
it's Jeremy Corbyn who's the question
mark we are keen to get a good bricks
that deal done
as soon as possible so we can move on to
talk in my case about things like
climate that's why I'm very excited to
be the international developers I want
to talk about climate I want to talk
about the environment
I want to reengage young people and I
don't want us to spend the next ten
years sitting in the studio talking
about the details of brexit yeah I look
forward to an interview that we can do
on things that aren't just about brexit
and but away from brexit I mean you've
had a bit of a roller coaster a week and
you were one of the beneficiaries of the
extrordinary sacking of Gavin Williamson
I will look at the paper today there's
some pretty
vicious briefing about governance it
wasn't there are you comfortable with
some of the stories that are coming out
people obviously leaking why I haven't
read all of that I say that first see he
was a an energetic defense minister and
I don't like criticizing colleagues
anyway at all equally the National
Security Council has to be kept secret I
mean it's it's the core the head of mi6
sits there ahead of mi5 sits there this
is where intelligence from our agents in
the field comes this is where
intelligence from United States and our
other allies comes it's unbelievably
important that we do a refresh so it
seems like unfortunately the Gavan
although he'd been an energetic defense
century appears to have repeated things
that were in that although he denies not
yeah I'm no mark said well who seems to
be at the center of this very well I've
known him back in the day when we were
both in Afghanistan together twelve
fourteen years ago I have enormous
admiration for him and I think that he
will have thought about this carefully
made the right step and the reason why
this is important is to be a serious
country in the world we've got to be
able to disagree with each other one of
the reasons we got in a mess in Iraq and
Afghanistan is we weren't good enough at
the equivalence the National Security
Council of really saying that isn't
going to work
in a way that could never leak because
sometimes the things you have to say
there you wouldn't want to see printed
in the papers you talked about knowing
someone said well are you concerned that
some of your colleagues seem to be
briefing against him in this tiff attack
yes absolutely I mean I think it's
incredibly important that our civil
servants are left totally out of this
one of the reasons I'm very proud of
your government is because of our civil
service they work all the hours that
that god they are incredibly dedicated
they're non-political people it's
totally unfair to put them in the firing
line yeah now just finally it's
refreshing to interview somebody who was
very open about the fact that you'd like
to be the next prime minister so are you
going to throw your hat in the ring when
there's a vacancy
yes but I am now so excited to be the
International Development Secretary and
to be honest the thing that matters even
more to me
and is getting this thing right because
climate change is the Cataclysm facing
us this is our biggest instrument to
engage with the environment
internationally potentially without
being too pretentious save the planet
and ultimately save us so what gets me
out of bed in the morning the reason I'm
proud and communicate this to my
two-year-old or my four-year-old is that
I think I've got the greatest gift on
earth to be the International
Development century it's I think you
need to let your colleagues know how
you've managed to do it how you've
managed to be completely open about the
fact that you want to be a prime
minister and yet you've somehow been
promoted and seen been seen as a
loyalist as well how does that happened
I think you just got to be straight I
mean if people feel that they would like
to go into that competition they should
say so and we should talk about what we
believe in and I think talking about
what we believe in matters in everyday
life but it also matters just in doing
good policy I felt this in prisons that
just being honest about not the waffle
but is this prison clean have we cleaned
out the garbage are we searching people
properly at the gate or in terms of
differed ok we're dealing with a bonus
thousand people have now died in DRC and
this is a disease that could come to
Britain again unless we deal with it but
it's also about being honest about
problems and refrigeration about that
fridge made in Bognor Regis by a British
company which is now in the jungles the
DRC and getting that right getting the
temperatures right getting the basics
right is the key to government there you
go an interview on everything from
brexit to fridges in Bognor Regis thank
you very much be on the program we'll
reach it thank you